because Gorbachev died you know the last  leader of the Soviet Union he was 91 and  I had this thought I said gorbache what  can we learn from history I said there's  some parallels here you got a very old a  dead guy so okay Soviet Union I'm  thinking of my own president right now  okay and uh it came to prominence in  politics in the 70s okay paddled around  with actual Communists okay this is  right now checking out gorby and Biden  uh they presided over the decline and  fall of their Nations and Empires okay  I'm seeing a whole lot of parallels here  except for one  Gorbachev tried to make his country  Freer and more transparent the only  there and he was sort of likable and  friends with Ronald Reagan I thought  gosh 30 years after the fall of the  Berlin Wall how on Earth do we the  people who won the Cold War how do we  find ourselves in this really awful  political do we learn nothing from the  Cold War